thank you
who doesn't love a good old ass kicking
in anime I know you do so I figured why
not use your like of those Showcases of
power for a good cause and exhibit some
notable examples from new anime I guess
this also makes a semi recommendation
video for new anime that just came out
in the last two years yes that's right
no sequels no long Runners just new
anime that got their start in the past
couple of years in the hopes that you
might find something new to pick up
that's enough talking from me and let's
get started
[Music]
we start off with a scene from fog Hill
of five elements
[Music]
Chinese anime has been making some
Headway in the recent years they'll
forever be left obscure for obvious
reasons such as marketing and such but
for those who decided to pick them up
they get rewarded by some cool fight
sequences with awesome animation and a
unique feel take this fog Hill Bridge
fight for example it really has that
comic free-flowing feel that makes you
think it's from a video game cutscene a
vintage game from the past decade or so
perhaps while the fight itself is an
awesome Showcase of power on the side of
the animators it's got a grand moment at
the end the scene gave me some eyes and
Vibes if you get what I'm saying
stopping an attack with a hand followed
by a one shot but this time it's done in
such a wild manner both in and out of
universe the smooth movement of lines
the whole shaky effect exploding
someone's head after choking them never
looked as intense before
next in line we have Rin versus brandy
remember inter-species reviewers yeah
that show that blew up for all the meme
reasons and whatnot surely the guy
behind it could have come up with
something even back here and crazier in
the grand scheme of things right well
he's got another title in his resume and
while it's not as attention grabbing as
inter-species reviewers it is still damn
cool that's either then deities it's got
some of the things you'd expect like the
profanity and the violence but it's also
got these amazing moments of character
flexes like Rin taking on Brandy around
if you will that drives home the fact
that Rin is one of the most powerful
characters in the show just when he
thought she's on the ropes she easily
pulls the comeback in the grandest way
possible even when it looked like she's
receiving a decisive hit Rin just easily
shrugs that attack off and wins nothing
short of expectations for the last
remaining either then
[Music]
yeah yeah
let's move on to Leo versus generals
from I'm quitting heroing
I'm quitting heroing is one of the shows
that I found quite interesting for the
year it's quite niche in the grand
scheme of things but I feel that it's a
show that lives off both its premise and
the idea that people just love
overpowered Heroes it's not every day we
see the scenario of the overpowered hero
getting the opposite of a hero's welcome
it's a no-brainer to understand what
Leo's capable of but this battle against
the generals is one of the times he
showcased it in a way that comes with an
insane wow factor while it's nothing as
comically over the top as snapping his
fingers and causing everyone to explode
it just shows how far ahead Leo is
compared to everyone he more than
deserves his reputation and in a Twist
he doesn't even look heroic doing all of
this normally showcases by the supposed
hero would be met by Tears of excitement
but for this moment he plays the villain
building so perfectly we can't help but
look in silence or struck
foreign
we then have doc Schneider's
introduction
for someone with as much hype as dark
Schneider coming in nothing less than a
bombastic first impression a Showcase of
power if you will would suffice
thankfully we got that and some in dark
Schneider's Awakening not even a few
seconds after returning dark Schneider
shows off his power by immediately
destroying two towering monsters before
flexing creation magic some banter
ensues but once the talking's over it's
back to the destruction we go and boy
did we get destruction the dark wizard
easily makes short work of every enemy
turning them into Pace with magic that
he fires off oh so easily sure an
impending catastrophe requires Extreme
Measures but these people better not
regret Awakening the most powerful
wizard of old in their quest to save
themselves for a widow dark Schneider
could be the cause of their Doom if
they're not careful rank 6 for me is
Right versus the clan leaders
foreign
[Music]
it's no secret that rye is one of the
most overpowered characters out there in
the world of webtoons it's just that
characters in Universe just decide to
stay blissfully ignorant of it possibly
due to [ __ ] arrogance and that when push
comes to shove the normally stoic right
will waste no time showing off the power
that's being laid to rest for hundreds
of years the biggest example is the
scene where the clan leaders decide to
attack him despite all the efforts by
these Clan leaders Ryan just stands
there looking as cool as ever those
attacks look like they could just about
eradicate any enemy with how they're
presented but it's too bad rise not just
any enemy after letting these Clan
leaders have their fun Rye response in
kind and it's an awesome scene to see
such is the power of Nobles
oh and if you're enjoying this video
then hurry up and hit that like button
up there to help the video with the
YouTube algorithm it shows that you will
appreciate videos like this and want
more and that could incentivize me to
make even more similar lists in the
future now we move on with gin Mori
versus Park irvio
because of the general positive yet
competitive atmosphere they give us when
Jim Mori and park ilpio battle it out in
this episode it felt like an impromptu
training session until it wasn't and
things got serious with the latter
releasing his nine tails form well how
does Jin respond to this sudden Twist by
taking it head-on of course it'll be it
may have shown off his shiny form along
with some super destructive attacks but
it just became the perfect opponent for
our protagonist to test his strength
against just to show us how strong our
protagonist really is he gets to face
the full might of ilpo's nine tails
transformation while calmly shrugging
off the force of the attacks Jin got it
in him to face the veritable pandemonium
head-on and came out on top this is one
of my favorite fights in the series and
it ended up with Jin showing the world
what he's really made of
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
than Mikey himself
yes the Invincible Mikey is here to
nobody's surprise in case you're
wondering whether he deserves that
nickname or not here's the fight against
Valhalla to convince you the gang war
eruption as all hell breaks loose we see
Mikey facing multiple people at once the
numbers game wasn't looking too good for
Mikey and he himself takes a thrashing
but that Invincible moniker isn't for
nothing despite all the punishment he
endures one rage moment is all it takes
for him to turn the tides on everyone he
starts no selling the shots before
Breaking Free and destroying every
opponent inside see that's the thing
about Mikey that I like he's not
Untouchable per se but after he lets you
have your fun and get your hits in then
it's payback time and payback courtesy
of this guy it ain't pretty
let's kick off the top three now with
arnos
[Music]
ahnos sealed away for ages only to
awaken into a world that he's unfamiliar
with a world that's grown weak when put
aside the power he had in him now this
kind of feels like Rye's backstory right
after what we've seen from right earlier
you might think that it's hard to top
that but this is arnos we're talking
about here this is a character whose
sure can give right a run for his money
we can start with how he makes his first
impression where else can you see
someone killing another guy without as
much as laying a finger on him only to
bring him back just to kill him again
all without breaking a sweat that's just
how powerful arnos is and he made sure
everyone was there to see it the guy
sure knows how to make a first
impression that will stick for the ages
arnos is crazy overpowered and he wastes
no time driving that point home who
knows what spectacular Feats he'll show
us this season too
[Applause]
our top two features none other than
orsted from mushoku tensei
the greatest villains proved their might
in the most memorable ways sometimes
that involves defeating some random slob
that's four times their size other times
it's going up against the hero team and
destroying everyone decisively and
that's exactly what allstead did before
this allstead already made a presence in
an encounter with a dragon but this is
the first time we've ever seen his Feats
in actual combat against the heroes and
boy did he make a mess out of dead end
there's simply no match for the dragon
God as we as fans were made to watch
what was nothing short of a massacre
it's a very dramatic sequence of events
that easily drove home the point that
this all stood is the real deal a true
challenge that rudius just won't be able
to overcome anytime soon
finally we have Gojo versus Miguel
[Music]
of course Gojo would be on the list but
while you would have expected something
out of the mainline series with his
numerous Feats out there I wanted to mix
things up just a little bit but we're
going to be going over something from
Jiu Jitsu Kaizen zero this time around
specifically his fight against Miguel
Miguel starts in the fight on the
offensive trying to attack Gojo but all
it does is open up the floodgates to
Gojo showing how overpowered he is
there's just so much to take away from
this fight you've got to think of
Miguel's rope and how quickly that thing
folded trying to seal Gojo's powers and
it's supposedly one of the most powerful
curse tools out there to be fair it
allowed him to hit Gojo a bit but that's
all she wrote before Gojo responds with
an eye-popping offensive featuring a
blitz of punches kicks and throws Gojo
just ended the fight within seconds and
to think that everyone had high
expectations for Miguel going in hey
let's at least give me girl credit for
surviving that many hits at once and
that ends my list of top 10 Showcases of
power in anime I know there are lots of
honorable mentions and moments that
arguably should be in here as well but
I'll leave that for you to discuss in
the comments section and who knows maybe
I'll feature them in a future video as
well as always thanks for watching this
video I hope you had fun I'd appreciate
it if you could also share my Channel
with your friends who might be
interested and I'll see you next time